slurpy just turned 50 years old
yeah we did it
USA we're not all bad I don't know if
you guys celebrated the way I did but
that weekend around the Slurpees
original birth date 711 had an amazing
promotion going on you go into any
7-eleven pay one dollar and fifty cents
and bring in the container of your
choice and fill it up with Slurpee an
America responded
people were bringing in like kiddie
pools trash bags a deep Rock jugs of
water we went nuts here's what I did
I'd de drank I got hammered I walked in
there about 1:00 a.m. confidently strode
to the register and I was like one pack
of Magnum condoms please
sir he slid the condoms across the
register I unwrapped him out of the
cellophane and then I just beelined over
to the celebrity machine just went right
up to it this proceeded to fill up 12
Magnum balloons full of Slurpee one
after another tied them all up scooped
them up my arms I was like see I the
Centennial dip shits
[Applause]